dass ein philosoph einen shitstorm
kassiert gibt es selten doch der satz
der seit ein paar wochen in der ganzen
schweiz zirkuliert stammt von einem
philosophen und er gab zu heftigen
kontroversen anlass 25 jahre ausruhen
ist eine bescheuerte perspektive lautet
er geschrieben hat in ludwig hasler
mit seinem witzigen plädoyer für ein
alter das noch was vorhat hat der manch
eine rentnerin manch einen pensionär vor
den kopf gestoßen
im kern schlag das buch allerdings die
alt werden geht in einer zeit in der wir
immer älter werden und wie die
generationen vor diesem hintergrund
konstruktiv zusammen leben können und
darf diskutieren wir jetzt am
philosophischen stammtisch und zwar mit
dem philosophen und publizisten ludwig
hasler der das buch geschrieben hat und
mit doris aebi
sie ist wirtschafts soziologin und
unternehmerin und mit stefan mann sei er
hat unter anderem philosophie studiert
und forschern der universität neuchâtel
zur migration vor allem aber ist der
frisch gebackener co-präsident der
operation libero herzlich willkommen
schon sind sie da ja herr hasler
sie schreiben in ihrem buch und ist ein
angriffs eigentlich dass die meisten
ihrer altersgenossen eine art passiv
mitgliedschaft oder sogar
ehrenmitgliedschaft in unserer
gesellschaft gelöst hätten sie gehen
wann waren sie spielen falls sie machen
kreuzfahrten nehmen aber keine pflichten
war wollten sie einfach provozieren
ja vielleicht dass auch die frage ist
immer nur mit widerspruch provozieren
also dass ich dem großen glück dass
dauernden herumreißen schlecht so
richtig trauen
das ist nur die eine geschichte
eigentlich eine nebengeschichte in der
hauptsache erzähle ich ja von der
enormen chance die das alter heute hat
also so etwas gab es ja noch nie in der
menschheitsgeschichte so viele von uns
leben so lange gesund unternehmens los
denn fit sind bei kräften
viele sind auch finanziell unabhängig
das heißt wir sind
wie keine anderen menschen und darum ist
ja eigentlich die frage logisch was
fangen wir an diesen wunderbaren
geschenkten 25 jahren das ist eigentlich
meine frage ich gehe davon der über
davon aus dass das nicht alle sind das
ist klar
ich habe mich einfach entschieden mit
dem buch erst mich mal an die zu
adressieren die noch die wahl haben wie
sie alt werden und die keine passive
mitgliedschaft lösen sollen die
rückmeldungen zu ihrem buch waren
allerdings heftig und ich zitiere aus
zuschriften die sie erhalten haben sie
haben die publik gemacht deswegen
erlaube ich mir das da schreibt jemand
wie das ein scheißkerl der vom leben
null ahnung habt oder entweder sie sind
schon so sind vertrottelt oder einfach
ein philosophischer klugscheißer und web
so einen schmarrn zu verzapfen schon
ziemlich hart
ja also damit habe ich nicht unbedingt
gerechnet aber das sind heute offenbar
so die üblichen höflichkeit in social
media
die meisten dieser angriffigen kurz die
stammen jahr aus dem schießstand das
heißt die reagieren nicht auf das buch
sondern auf journalistische schlagzeilen
haben sich nicht ganz unschuldig bin
natürlich aber aber die richtig main wer
sich da und anschütz thoms beteiligt hat
conzzeta nie dazu ein buch zu lesen
und wenn ich die reaktionen auf das buch
daneben setzte es sind die komplett am
das also ich kenne nicht eine negative
reaktion zum buch und es läuft ja auch
nach wie vor ein prächtiges wird sehr
viel verschenkt also sie glauben gar
nicht wie viele frauen zu mir kommen mit
der bitte ob ich vielleicht eine widmung
schreiben könnte sie möchten das buch
ihrem mann geschenken der demnächst
pensioniert werden also die die haben ja
die panik wenn sie daran denken dass der
mann mit 63 jetzt plötzlich die ganze
zeit zu hause ist
freilich hätten sich vielleicht jetzt
nicht so ausgedrückt wie diese
zuschriften aber haben sie sich über
diese thesen mit der passive
mitgliedschaft zum beispiel auch dr
also kehrte er nicht ich habe mir
überlegt wie das kommt oder weil im buch
geht es vor allem auch tun wie geschaut
ob man diese 25 jahre und ich glaube
aber was das problem ist natürlich dass
das dass diese punkte von den
kreuzfahrten und das golfen und
eigentlich dieses lusti feeds ihren des
letzten lebensabschnittes dass das
natürlich schon produziert und ich habe
mir einfach in die zahlen zu schauen des
bundesamtes für statistik
wie ja wie sieht das so angst so wie wir
leben eigentlich die rentner von was
leben die order und wenn man schaut die
ahv ja das klar dass das haben die
rentner aber nur zwei drittel haben eine
zweite säule und knapp ein viertel hat
die dritte säule frau und noch viel viel
weniger weil die vielen weniger lang
natürlich im arbeitsleben waren also das
ist das ein oder wenn wir dann sehen
dass zehn prozent aller ahv bezüger
ergänzungsleistungen beziehen
dann sitzt noch mal drastisch an und das
ist dass für solche leute dann schon
eigentlich eine eine faust ins auge die
sich dann wirklich quasi jeden rappen ab
sparen müssen um dann vielleicht mal
irgendwo eine kleine übernachtung zu
machen und dann kommt noch etwas anderes
dazu wir sind zwar eines der reichsten
länder aber die schweiz
da kommen wir sicher auch noch darauf zu
sprechen hat ja auch diesen
generationenvertrag die solidarität
zwischen den generationen und da habe
ich dann auch geschaut was macht dann
eigentliche die ältere generation und
freiwilligenarbeit und das ist dann auch
wieder toll zu sehen dass eigentlich bei
der freiwilligenarbeit vor allem bei den
informellen für eigentlichen arbeit das
ist nicht das was man nicht in einem
verband oder in einen kulturellen freien
oder qualitativ macht sondern eben das
informelle in der familie bei bekannten
sind 33 prozent aller über 65 jährigen
die sich da engagieren um 22 bei den
institutionellen das einfach das möchte
ich ihnen einfach auch ein bisschen in
den raum stellen und einfach auf zu
zeigen weil ich mir einfach überlegt
warum hat das so ein shitstorm ausgelöst
wird darum vielleicht von sauren
leuchten da genau das entzündet sich ja
wirklich auch am begriff der passive
mitgliedschaft ich wird nachher gleich
noch gerne darüber sprechen ich würde
gerne zu wirst
ihnen noch kommen hermann saeco
präsident neu der operation libero es
ist ja so diese ganze diskussion um den
generationenvertrag und wie wir
eigentlich ort werden wie das auch für
die jungen ist wenn immer mehr menschen
alt sind in unserem land kommt ja auch
dadurch zustande dass wir viel länger
leben
25 jahre passive mitgliedschaft ist
natürlich keine perspektive was sagen
sie dazu
ja also ich glaube zunächst kann man
auch festhalten das ist natürlich eine
schöne perspektive 25 jahre oder länger
zu leben nach der pensionierung heute
gleichzeitig stellen sich gewisse fragen
die er hat in seinem buch eben sehr
tiefgründig auch errichtet wie ich finde
ich habe mir auch ähnliche fragen
gestellt also was heißt das genau
passive mitgliedschaft oder umgekehrt
wie definieren wir was sich nützlich
machen heißt das heißt es einen beitrag
zu leisten werde bestimmt das oder ist
das nur monetär beispielsweise und
andererseits auf die frage wie also wie
gehen wir damit um dass wir von dieser
basis mitgliedschaft sprechen also
vielleicht einfach wie ja nein ich würde
fragen was eigentlich in deutschland
wieder stehen wir diese leistung und
dann vielleicht auch wie sie sagen der
mensch ist ja sehr aktiv ohr gerät ist
nicht in sich hat ist ein
extrovertiertes ein exzentrisches wesen
wie sie sagen und was bedeutet das gibt
es überhaupt ein problem mit dieser
passivität also haben wir nicht stellt
sich die frage wie wollen wir uns alle
aktiv einbringen und wir können mir das
erlauben für die gesamte gesellschaft
aber auch unabhängig vom alter zum
beispiel ich würde gerne mit ihnen
diesen begriff der passive
mitgliedschaft weiter kritisch
hinterfragen und ganz kurz in einem clip
schauen der von pro senectute die haben
nämlich zu zeigen versucht eben wie
aktiv sich viele alte menschen
beteiligen an der gesellschaft
[Musik]
ja das sieht ja wirklich nicht besonders
passivhaus häßler
also es gibt ja es gibt ja verschiedene
formen von aktivität
also wenn ich mich daran erinnere wie
eine vor
ich weiss nicht wie vielen jahren so der
begriff des aktiven senioren aufkam
der meinte aktivität ausschließlich eine
bewegung mit sich selbst
also das heißt diese chemische oder sind
permanenten bewegt ich habe mir dann
überlegt ja das ist wunderbar aber 25
jahren hält das trinken das ist ja immer
die frage ich dass man kann vielerlei
kann man auch sehr sinnvoll betrachten
in einer kurzen zeit in einer art in
dieser frist die früher das alte war das
so das auslaufen dass sich vorbereiten
auf auf ein anderes leben möglicherweise
übergang um so und jetzt den schicht das
plötzlich aus also wenn das so weiter
geht ist nämlich dann das und das
pensionierten leben gleich lang wie das
erwerbsleben dass das ist eigentlich
fast absehbar und also müssen wir uns ja
gedanken machen und meine idee mit dem
buch war der vor allem dass wir uns
sozusagen aktiv gedanken machen muss
nicht viel vieles machen wir einfach
jetzt so automatisch und ich meine haare
sind natürlich glücklich aber es gibt
dann immer noch gut die hälfte
die da durch und können immer ganz ganz
konkret haben ich mein viele viele
menschen haben sehr viel gearbeitet
viele haben noch kinder großgezogen vor
allem die frauen gilt denn diese these
nicht mehr man darf nach einem reichen
arbeitsleben sich zur ruhe setzen
stimmt das nicht mehr ja also ich würde
genau da ansetzen also ist es wirklich
ein zur ruhe setzen oder was heißt das
genau ich komme im frauen aus dem
migrationspolitischen diskurs darauf
hinaus geschlechterforschung stellt sich
häufig die frage wie definiert diese
nützlichkeit oder den bürgerrechten
die teilnahme im wirtschaftsleben häufig
ist es dann eine website steuern zahlen
und so weiter und dass wir zu recht
kritisiert dass eine verengte
wahrnehmung von was das heißt einen
beitrag zu leisten oder nützlich zu sein
aus der feministischen forschung auch
eben diese ganze care arbeit geben nicht
abgedeckt wird dadurch und ich glaube
hier müssen wir uns schon fragen und das
sind fragen die auch ein beim
grundeinkommen immer wieder aufkommen
oder bei einem bürgerdienst
beispielsweise was zählt überhaupt aus
als beitrag in der gesellschaft oder als
leistung und ich glaube ich hier haben
wir die tendenz ein viel zu frühes bild
davon zu haben anstatt davon auszugehen
dass alle in irgendeiner form per se mal
einen beitrag leisten auch leisten
wollen ich würde da gerne auch die
großmütter revolution erwähnen dass eine
denkfabrik von ungefähr 300 frauen im
rentner art im pensionsalter die sich
immer wieder zu wort melden die auf
kundgebungen veranstaltung die haben
einmal die zahl genannt dass sie gesagt
haben unbezahlte kinderbetreuung
geleistet von großmüttern und großvätern
waren großmüttern entspricht einem
geldwert von ungefähr 8 milliarden
schweizer franken pro jahr
das ist wahrscheinlich das worauf sie
hinaus wollten verhindern dass sie
gesagt haben dass taucht vielleicht
nicht auf irgendwo in einer statistik
oder so aber das ist sagt es ist
unglaublich viel was die beitragen
also ich glaube es ist wichtig eben
diese zahlen auch immer wieder zunehmend
sie haben jetzt diese spezifische
segment der groß mittlere angesprochen
das ist extrem wichtig damit überhaupt
die frauen die im berufsleben sind und
vor und kinder und familie haben
überhaupt erwerbstätig sein können
und da kommen wir eben wieder zu meinen
punkt zurück oder wir haben die ganzen
sozialen systeme in der schweiz die
soziale sicherheit das 3 soll im prinzip
ist eigentlich aufgebaut auf einer
langjährigen berufstätigkeit zuerst
ausbildung dann berufstätigkeit bis 65
bei den frauen etwas tiefer und dann in
rente und ich glaube einfach punkt eins
wir können uns das nicht mehr
finanzieren diese 25 jahre passive
mitgliedschaft was ich eben klage ist es
eben nicht das ist keine passive
mitgliedschaft sondern die sind schon
jetzt sehr aktiv auch da vielleicht eine
eine zahl auf die ahv gegründet
gute 1948 kam ein pensionierter auf 6
erwerbstätige 2010 waren es auch für
erwerbstätige und 20 50 noch zwei
erwerbstätig das heißt es lässt sich
irgendwann nicht mehr finanzieren oder
und deshalb bei der kirche müssen wir
das ganze system der sozialen vorsorge
das ist ja auch im parlamentarischen
prozess drinnen überdenken wir müssen
uns auch überlegen wie wir das machen
mit der demografischen entwicklung
einfach dazu noch ein satz oder diese
fachkräfte fehlen weil jetzt ist die
geburtenstarken die kommen jetzt dann in
rente ja die bis zu 65 jährigen diese
täte also jahrgang 65 die sind jetzt 55
aber die sind in zehn jahren auch in
rente und dort ist dann diese große
pablo in rente und tanz wenig es ist
jetzt ein bisschen akzentuiert müssen
das finanzieren das geht nicht an
und deshalb sage ich einfach wir müssen
grundsätzlich darüber sprechen wie
finanzieren wir die rente ja und wie
können wir eben flexibilisieren damit
ähneln und individualisieren damit eben
auch ältere arbeitnehmende im
arbeitsprozess können beiden kliniken
nein ja ich glaube das sind die das sind
die großen fragen und habe ich würde
vielleicht noch einen schritt weiter
gehen und sagen es ist nicht nur eine
frage die sich ob die rente dann für die
rente stellt sondern für das
arbeitsleben in zukunft wurde also mit
dem ganzen digitalisierung zukunft der
arbeit und so weiter verschiedene neue
arbeitsmodelle familienmodelle und da
ist die frage eng verknüpft wie
finanzieren wir das alles und auch die
frau geben der sinnhaftigkeit wir haben
gesagt jungen heute ist sie wollen ein
sinnvolles tun
genau diese fragen dass wir wie das
zusammen denken und überlegen wie können
wir erreichen wir eine gesellschaft in
der alle sich möglichst frei entfalten
können und wir gleichzeitig ein system
haben in dem sich alle betätigen und wie
das auch finanzieren
und natürlich auch genügend mitarbeiter
hatten wegen diesem demografischen
wandel den ich geschrieben habe ist
diese frage eben passive mitgliedschaft
wollen wir nicht wie denken wir darüber
nach ich glaube da gibt es wie zwei
ebenen was sie beschäftigt ist ja sehr
stark die denken wir im
alter überhaupt über uns selbst nach was
ist eine sinnvolle existenz da möchte
ich dann später im gespräch auch noch
darauf zurückkommen jetzt sind wir ja
mehr bei der frage was ist eine gerechte
gesellschaft können wir es uns überhaupt
leisten dass menschen so lange zeit zu
passiv mitgliedern werden oder ein teil
von ihnen zu passiv mitgliedern werden
nun haben sie sagen sie im buch ja auch
hallo ihr lieben leute da draußen wir
alten menschen sind eigentlich
fachkräfte dann stellt sich die frage
werden wir eigentlich noch genügend
nachgefragt dass es gebe ja viele die
wollen sie vielleicht einbringen
aber man fragt sie gar nicht erleben sie
das so herrscht ja aber gut ich meine es
gibt eigentlich zwei parzellen die die
wir getrennt besprechung menschen die
eine parzelle ist arbeitsleben wie lange
und wie die wii können ältere mit ihrer
erfahrung sich da noch beteiligen und
wie lange wir das ihnen ermöglicht oder
verunmöglicht und so weiter das ist die
eine große freude und wir haben da sage
ich einfach meine sicht einfach viel zu
wenig fantasie
wir sind total fantasie in dieser
wirtschaftlich finster was wäre ein
vorschlag wäre dass wir uns einfach mal
schlicht fragen was können die jungen
super was haben die alten was die jungen
eher nicht haben
kurze antwort die jungen haben das
frischere wissen dass sie haben mehr
erhofft ich jetzt machen sie haben mehr
illusion enden war ganz wichtig für die
zukunft wir alten haben nicht mehr das
frischeste wissen nicht wie wir sind
nicht mehr so begierig auf die neuesten
studien
wir haben vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger illusionen haben wir ein wenig
kaum noch aber wir haben das was mal
erfahrung gießen erfahrung ist etwas was
man nicht lernen kann das kann man nicht
erwerben erfahrung braucht zeit
erfahrung kommt mit der zeit
erfahrung ist etwas ganz anderes als das
lern bahre wissen erfahrung ist
sozusagen das lebens und praxis
gesättigte wissen
dazu braucht man viel zeit das heißt
übrigens nicht dass alle automatisch
erfahrung machten
mit den jahren aber es braucht zeit und
wenn wir jetzt dass wir hätten eine
lieblingsidee nicht das zusammenspiel
zwischen jung und alt wenn wir jetzt die
stärken der jungen wissen lotion
verheiratet mit der stärke der alten mit
der erfahrung
dann wären wir unschlagbar aus
gesellschaft und das machen sie nicht
sie haben gesagt das hat mich total
erstaunt operation libero da denken
immer alle eine ganz jugendbewegung sie
sagen ein drittel ihrer aktiven
mitglieder sind über 65
ja also fragen an den stammtischen also
wirklich auch an den an den events dann
oder auch auf die straßen einen flyer
verteilen
ja was natürlich auch damit zu tun hat
wir haben vor allem junge leute
studieren de die zeit haben oder dem
pensionierten die dann auch mit dem mehr
zeit haben für politisches engagement
und deshalb ich würde mich da ein
bisschen dagegen wäre neben dass dieses
konstrukt des generationenkonflikts das
wirklich so zu nennen oder diese
kategorien einzuteilen
weil ich ihm glaube es hängt viel auch
von politischen werten und einstellungen
ab wie man sich positioniert und das ist
nicht nur eine frage des alters
also umgekehrt vielleicht werde ich auch
vor sich gegeben diese diese natürlich
diese positiven attribute jung alt
wieder zu festigen stein zu meistern
wie sieht es jetzt vorschlagen weil ich
glaube da ist auch ein gewisses risiko
dass man das eben dann wieder diese
kategorien schafft und damit auch wieder
vorurteile und klischees vielleicht
verhärtet anstatt zu sagen ja nein es
gibt einfach junge die schon sehr viel
erfahrung haben in gewissen bereichen
und alte die noch voller tatendrang sind
nur darum wichtig weil ich gerade aus
wirtschaftskreisen dauernd höhere höher
auf von erfahrung zu reden die seine
erfahrung das ist der größte
innovationskraft und die interpretiere
neben erfahrung völlig anders nicht also
das heißt dass das behaupten eines
früheren wissens das ist das dann nicht
mehr vorwärts geht und ich meine eben
dass wir damit beginnen müssten die
erfahrung die ich meine wieder schätzen
zu lernen wir schätzen wir alte schätzen
sie sich selber nicht mehr wer also ich
höre ja dauernd gleichaltrigen sagen die
ängste seien schon viel schlauer als
vr die erfahrung als innovations-
killers haben sie mal was dazu sie haben
ja als hätte unter ihnen sagen sie immer
mal wieder schwierigkeiten menschen über
65 und verwaltungsräte zu vermitteln
obwohl sie gerne würden und denken das
wäre wichtig ein gutes verwaltungsseitig
gesagt vielleicht etwas in etwas
spezielles weil das ist ja in dem sinne
ein nebenamt 1 1 1 ein teilzeit an
das problem ist natürlich in einem
verwaltungsrat sollte man eine gewisse
zeit mitwirken weil es geht um die
strategische entwicklung des
unternehmens und da braucht einfach eine
gewisse zeit und da sind dann autos
beschränkungen jetzt mit 70 man kann
natürlich auch darüber sprechen ist das
macht dass sie noch das nicht sehen oder
aber sie ist für mich vielleicht nicht
der hotspot der die wirtschaft
beschäftigt ob er jetzt 65 jährige ob
jetzt in großen zahlen verwaltungsseite
kommen sondern was eigentlich viel
wichtiger ist ist das wie wir es
schaffen diesen fachkräftemangel den ich
vorher angesprochen habe der durch die
durch die demografische entwicklung
entsteht also das heißt es gekommen die
geburten stark die geburtenschwachen
jahrgänge kommen jetzt langsam
es sind jetzt im berufsleben übernehmen
immer mehr verantwortung und eigentlich
das fachwissen die die der dieser großen
population der person wird immer mehr
ins rentenalter kommen die scheiden aus
und das ist eigentlich sehr viel wissen
verloren
und darum weil man von erfahrung spricht
ist das sicher schon so dass erfahrung
aus dem unternehmen ist wichtig das
wissen ist wichtig weil gerade in der
industrie geht natürlich ganz viel
fachwissen verloren gehe wenn die leute
dann in rente gehen und darum plädiere
ich ja eigentlich sehr stark für dieses
modell der bogen karriere dass sich die
wirtschaft auch jetzt zunehmen da
einfügt gebe ich sie sagen eine
sinuskurve das eben nicht nur raser
bogen heißt eigentlich eine karriere war
bislang einfach immer nach oben
gerichtet oder man hat immer mehr
verantwortung mehr führung erläutern
übernommen und dann irgendwann mit 65
taq feld runter und was man eigentlich
sagt das ist eigentlich nicht gut weil
vor allem in zeiten wie jetzt wo wir in
eine transformation leben also immer
mehr in die digitalisierung
da braucht es anderes wissen ja da kommt
vielleicht der punkt dass man sagt diese
erfahrung sei nicht so gewünscht es ist
eine andere erfahrung die die ältere
generation nicht bringt dieses
fachwissen und die bogen karriere sagt
dann einfach dass man eigentlich sagt so
vielleicht auch da nicht eine alte
festgenommen
das ziel dann ist so in der lebensmitte
dass man sagt man gibt es zunehmend
verantwortung ab in der führung
man übernimmt er projekte man stellt
sein wissen als internet berater
beraterin zur verfügung und eigentlich
dass die jüngeren dann stärker in die
führungsaufgabe reingehen aber das
braucht natürlich eine ganz neue
unternehmenskultur badewanne ist dort
von diesen stereotypen ja und vor allem
auch eine bereitschaft dann wiederum auf
der seite von den jungen auch wirklich
zuzuhören und sich unter umständen auch
noch eine weile lang bisschen rein reden
zu lassen
kehren wir doch den spieß mal um also
wir blicken eigentlich die älteren
generationen auf die jüngeren kürzlich
war die rede von einer juvenilen
verbitterung der jungen generation da
hieß es irgendwie denken 1980 zürich
brannte da hieß es noch er macht aus dem
staat gurkensalat heute haben wenn man
die neueste jugendbefragung anschaut
zwei drittel aller jugendlichen wünschen
sich eine familie mit zwei kindern ein
drittel träumt sogar davon dass der mann
100 prozent arbeitet ev möglichst
teilzeit oder gar nicht so lange die
kinder noch klein sind also der
generationenkonflikt ist ja nicht nur in
die richtung der arten sondern auch in
die richtung von der älteren generation
auf die jüngere hermann sie ja aber ich
würde mich wieder wehren gegen diese
strikte kategorisierung gewissermaßen
weil ich glaube klar die generation ist
geprägt von vom gesellschaftlichen
kontext von bestimmten historischen
ereignissen vom technologischen
entwicklungen vielleicht aber
gleichzeitig ist es eben kann man sich
wie nicht so festlegen oder ich meine
die klima jugend ist extrem politisch
zum beispiel das ist ein change ist auch
sehr weitgehend eine forderung unter
umständen
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich
irgendwie extrem konservativ sind auch
in gewissem sinne
wir haben aber auch alte die auf
kreuzfahrten gehen und dann für die
ökologie kritisiert werden wir haben die
jungen die aber auch generation easyjet
genannt werden weil sie die ganze zeit
um fliegen also ich glaube es ist
wirklich schwierig das einfach auf die
auf die generationen aufzudrücken und zu
sagen ein generationenkonflikt das würde
heißt wenn ich sie ernst nehme es gibt
kein generationenkonflikt ja ja ja
wirklich sonst würde ich absolut zu so
darlegen ja weil wir haben fragen im
klima wir haben fragen bei der beide
vorsorge mit dieser politischen
fixierung auf die grenze zwischen
erwerbsleben und keinen schmerz leben
wie sie das genannt haben aber ich
glaube dass sie eben das sind politische
fragen und ich da richtet sich das nach
politischen werten und überzeugungen die
bei jungen und alten sehr
unterschiedliche und sehr ähnlich sein
können und innerhalb von einer
generation cd wird ich wäre gerne ändern
dass ich nur ganz kurz ein es auch sagen
es ist natürlich schon einfach die
generation so zwischen 30 und 50 jahren
dort hat man familie dort hat man beruf
macht weiterbildungen das ist die
generation die jetzt der träger der
wirtschaft ist oder ob ich meine an
denen hängt so viele lasten oder gibt es
ist die generation die hat nicht so
viele menschen wie wie die ältere
generation
das heißt dass er auch mit den ganzen
fragen wie finanziert sich eben die
rente in zukunft und das beschäftigt
diese generation der 30 bis 50 jahren
extrem oder und dieser
freiwilligenarbeit ich gesagt hab da
hängt ein extrem viele an und für diese
generation glaube ich müssen wir sorge
tragen
und vielleicht können wir ja auch noch
sagen der generationenvertrag ist schon
unter druck nicht nur wegen der zahlen
die sie genannt haben
wie viele menschen eigentlich für eine
rente aufkommen müssen
die haben ja richtig gesagt früherer 16
in zukunft werden es noch zwei sein also
die last nimmt extrem zu sondern es gibt
ja auch noch viele andere themen also
dass zb für die bildung die budgets
dauernd gekürzt werden sind themen für
die jungen dann gibt es das klimaproblem
es gibt aber auch zum beispiel die
tatsache dass es für junge sehr
schwierig ist nach wohneigentum zu
erwerben wer ein haus erbt hat glück
gehabt sonst ist die schweiz eine schon
vergebenen zugebaut erben wiederum da
habe ich auch mal nachgeschaut werden
beim erben ist es so sechs von zehn
erben sind über 60 das heißt das
vermögen kumuliert sich eigentlich
wiederum in der älteren generation also
ich staune dass sie sagen es gibt
überhaupt gar keine probleme zwischen
den generationen nein ich glaube ich
sagen eben beispiele bildung also wenn
die wenn sage ich jetzt mal die alten
bei den jungen bei der bildungs- sport-
und dann ist das kein schnitt ins eigene
fleisch weil er genau darüber tragen
wieder in zukunft die rente finanziert
werden so zum beispiel oder beim klima
logisch werden die jungen noch länger in
dieser welt leben müssen
aber es gibt genauso viele ältere
menschen die sich für den klimaschutz
ihr leben lang engagiert haben und immer
noch engagieren auch mit der perspektive
dass eben ihre nachkommen
diese möglichkeiten ermöglichen also ich
glaube nicht dass man sagen kann bildung
oder klima sind jung gegen alt zu themen
das ist aber das sind jetzt genau themen
wo ich klar wo sich die generation
extrem solidarisieren
weil die älteren wie die jungen wollen
wollen den nachkommen rheine eine
gesunde ehrte weitergeben
gutes klima oder also dort findet man
sich oder aber irgendwann werden einfach
die finanziellen lasten für genau diese
tragende bevölkerungsschicht zu groß und
darüber hinaus laufen wir wenn wir das
nicht schaffen eben einen
mehrheitsfähigen neuen
generationenvertrag im bereich der
sozialen sicherheit zu schaffen weil
diese 25 jahre
die oder und die werden ja in der länge
die man dann in nach heutigem system hat
im alter und dann eben nicht mehr
erwerbstätig ist oder zu wenig beitrag
und die gesellschaft liebe das kostet
das soll die erwerbstätige bevölkerung
ist jukic immer weniger leute die nicht
nochmals und einfach nochmals betonen
nicht genügend betonen ich glaub das ist
einfach ein buch verfasst
also da muss ich jetzt auch nun fragen
ist denn das was jetzt sagen ein
plädoyer sozusagen auf in die richtung
von herrn hasler möchten sie quasi sagen
die menschen die über 65 sind sollen auf
gar keinen fall aus dem berufsleben
ausscheiden oder ist es ein plädoyer
dafür die institutionen gegen die
umzubauen
also das wichtigste wäre die institution
umzubauen uhr bin ich auch realistisch
genug dass ich weiß das geht nicht von
heute auf morgen müssen wir maßnahmen
ergreifen die kurz und mittelfristig
greifen und das ist dass er eben diese
barriere wie ich sie vorher gesagt aber
das machen viele unternehmen und es
nicht auch da eine kultur in den
unternehmen die das amt zu lassen
dass die jüngeren auch das toll finden
dass dann ältere in ebel eine
faxfunktion eingehen und dafür länger im
arbeitsprozess drinnen preise gibt auch
genauso den begriff die sesselkleber
sexuell weil die person übernimmt er
dann auch andere funktionen oder 7 nimmt
andere funktion oder durch marin wieder
ländern auf dem sessel gesessen hat
plötzlich auf dem tablett lassen das
darf man eben nicht so darstellen da
sind eben auch wieder stereotypen und
ich glaube eben gerade mit der
digitalisierung auch da ist es klar in
der wirtschaft ist es ist es braucht
agile organisationsformen flache
hierarchien und das kommt die
unternehmen sind doch viel weiter wie
wir denken oder und arbeiten daran dass
eben genau solche systeme möglich sind
oder und das gilt es zu unterstützen und
nicht zu zehn hantieren mit euren
bildern sind wir aber dann einverstanden
dass eben nicht ein jung gegen alt im
stereotypen sinn ist sondern dass auch
ich sie verstehe ein unter 65 gegenüber
65 und wie verhält sich das auch punkto
finanzierung vor allem und vielleicht
etwas salopp gesagt könnte man sagen
jetzt ist es so dass die unter
65-jährigen ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen für die über 65-jährigen
finanzieren und das wird immer ein
gewisses ungleichgewicht geraten und
deshalb müssen wir diese worden das ist
aber dass moment es ist ein kerniges ab
und zu würden sie dem zustimmen herr
hasler die unter 65-jährigen finanzieren
ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen für
die über 65-jährigen
also ich finde es schwierig in dieser
kürze über das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen und ich bin im prinzip
dagegen und zwar als anthropologischen
gründen nicht aus weil es eben nicht
mehr nur der lebensabend ist sondern der
lebens nachmittag ließ ja selber sagen
weil ja nicht nur noch fünf jahre leben
sondern 25
vielleicht irgendwann 35 nach fünf oder
noch mehr und man darf natürlich auch
nicht vergessen lassen wir kurz herrn
hasler vielleicht zu bekommen wo waren
wir sie haben nur vorhin gesagt sie
würden gerne etwas sagen deswegen wollte
ich hin das wort geben aber dann lassen
die kurz frau wie weiter ich würde
eigentlich einen
für die generation 65 schlagen oder weil
die haben ja auch jahre lang einbezahlt
das darf man nicht vergessen oder also
glücklich ich bin als ist gesagt hat man
das nicht sich verdient dass man sich
jetzt mal zurück liegt das ist bis zu
einem gewissen grad stimmt das natürlich
oder aber es ist ein system das bewegt
sich und die rahmenbedingungen da
rundherum ändern sich und wenn wir einen
demografischen wandel haben wie ich es
sage dass es eben weniger leute gibt die
eben die rente von ganz vielen
finanzieren muss dann kommt das system
in schieflage und das ist dort wo mir
das sorgen macht wegen dem
generationenvertrag
aber ich habe auch verständnis
logischerweise für die generation die
eben auch in der sozialisierung sich
gewohnt ist es gibt ein leben mit diesen
klaren etappen ausbildung beruf rente
das ist ganz tief sozialisiert bei den
rentnerinnen und rentner das kenne ich
auch von meinen eltern her das ist es
ist mir nicht fremd oder aber ich sage
einfach wir müssen genau an diese
denkweise überbrücken und vor allem
jetzt auch die jetzt von den
geburtenstarken jahrgänge und jetzt noch
im erwerbsleben sind die möglichst lange
im erwerbsleben behalten und denen
möglichkeiten schafft und dass sie
wenden wollen und vielleicht je nachdem
wie schnell sich daneben die
grundlegenden änderungen machen lassen
bezüglich sozialer sicherheit dann auch
länger arbeiten müssten
jetzt stehen sie wieder gehört habe habe
ich hab ich den vater und ich glaube wir
sind uns einig wenn wir sagen
entscheidend ist die
unternehmenskulturen ja je nachdem mögen
die älteren länger drinbleiben oder
nicht man bietet ihnen was attraktives
an oder eben nicht und so weit her kann
ich noch nicht scheint mit dieser neuen
betriebskultur denn wenn ich die zahl
richtig im kopf haben sind es 58 prozent
aller die in der schweiz arbeiten die
frühpensioniert werden wollen
sie wollen früh pensioniert werden also
das scheint nicht jetzt ein begierde auf
diese art von arbeit recht sondern eher
die distanzierung so schnell wie möglich
und jetzt noch zu der generation ich
meine sie kennen natürlich vor allem die
alten die mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
das in eine bestimmte gruppe von ups ich
kenne auch die andere gruppe
und natürlich gibt es durch die
unterschiedlichen sozialisations typen
gibt es generationen merkmalen die dann
irgendwie auch wieder die fonds werden
das ist klar aber also meine generation
ist natürlich mit blick auf arbeit zum
beispiel so aufgewachsen erst die arbeit
dann das vergnügen
das war gut für den fleiß für die
disziplin für wird als wir das richtige
arbeit aber das hieß auch das vergnügen
beginnt erst wenn die arbeit zu ende ist
und das ist auch ein problem also am
wochenende am feierabend und nach der
pensionierung das ist die große illusion
dass dann sozusagen der große traum vom
glück ihm nichts tun weil die aber das
vergnügen konnte erst nach der arbeit
und wenn ich mit jungen zusammen arbeite
also mit millennials ist das völlig
anders redet also die die haben halt
auch nie erfahren dass man arbeit muss
unbedingt
es ist ja irgendwie alles funktioniert
ja darum waren die jungen ja auch gegen
die frühen lockerungen carola
mehrheitlich viel mehr als wir denken
dass das leben funktioniert
man kann die wirtschaft so platzieren
und so aber jetzt nur noch einen satz
zum unterschied die jungen denke nicht
erst die arbeit dann das vergnügen weil
arbeit muss ja nicht unbedingt sein fürs
leben aber die kehren den stars jetzt
schon und sagen wir wollen das vergnügen
einarbeiten und ich kann jetzt vergnügen
auch noch durchsetzen und dann haben wir
es nämlich und das ist ein markanter
unterschied ist ganz wichtig und darf
ich noch mal zu ihrer generation auch
fragen warum nennen sie die generation
der jetzigen sio niert sind die
verwöhntesten generation die je gelebt
hat nicht die je gelebt hat um die je in
schalter kam das sind riesen
unterschiedlich main wie ich weiß ganz
genau ich komme aus atmen
erhältlich sind also ich war nie
verwöhnt was wir wirklich nicht wer und
warum ich das nennen er das war sie also
als eine provokation natürlich aber wenn
man wenn man liest merkt man wie es
gemeint ist ich sage ja nur wer sich in
meiner generation mühe gab er hat ein
tag in als aufwärts gehen immer auf wir
hatten keine katastrophe ich habe nicht
eine erlebt also aus gesellschaft die
wirtschaft funktioniert ja es gab immer
mehr es gab immer schönere autos es gab
voller kühlschrank es gab händisch es
gab spitex usw
die heutige jugend hat eine völlig
andere welt was ich diese welt ist offen
und extrem ungewiss
bei uns war alles klar ein bisschen mühe
eine aus bild wer eine ausbildung
gemacht hat hat rangiert ist klar das
ist heute komplett anders nach meiner
ansicht und ich meine jetzt die 80
bewegung oder ich habe natürlich die
achtundsechziger nach ins tal
ich meine wir lebten unter
einschränkungen da und wollte die
gesellschaft unsere freiheit kraft also
wir zum lebensrecht 68 und nachher
pflasterstein die heutige jugend ist so
hat das kürzlich nur kolumnistin gesagt
ist durch befreit
sie ist irgendwie doof befreit wie soll
sie gegen war schon sie eigentlich
rebellieren gegen ganz genau sind sie
durch bereit
nein ich glaube nicht ich glaube es gibt
aus progressive sie nicht 68 es nicht so
der sexualität oder was auch immer wir
nehmen wollen wir noch viele bereiche wo
wir längst nicht da sind wo wir
hinkommen könnten aus bürgersicht und
andere hat ihn ich bin nicht mehr ich
nicht ganz wohl bei dieser bei dieses
stückchen unterscheidungen dienen die in
die generationen aus einerseits eben
puncto nicht arbeiten wollen oder oder
arbeit und dann das vergnügen ich nach
ein paar tagen in den ferien ist mir
langweilig und ich will etwas tun und
ich glaube es gibt viele menschen zu und
das geht auch im alter noch so also
dieses tätig sein wollen
ich glaube das ist menschlich wie sie
das schreiben im buch oder auch ja ich
glaube andere tätigkeit es geht nur über
das geht das ist genau mein tapings oder
nicht tätigkeit schon um sinnvoll
genau das war unsere generation nicht so
furchtbar wichtig zwischen aber geht es
riecht auch darum beizutragen zu einem
größeren ganzen seien im grunde genommen
könnte man ja dann auch fragen ich mein
wandern gehen golf spielen was sie noch
alles in der generation vorwerfen sind
ja auch sinnvolle und schöne tätigkeiten
und was jetzt gefordert wird von frau
emmi ist ja sehr viel stärker auch sich
eben einzubringen als fachkraft also
wirklich weiterhin in einer bestimmten
ordnung weist berufstätig war es schon
zu sein und ich bin nur sage ich werde
das natürlich keinen menschen vor
ich frage mich nur ob das als glück für
25 jahre das ist alles ich hab doch
nichts gegen reich und ich habe nix golf
spielt ich habe nichts schreibt ich
glaube das leben ist wie ein portfolio
das man man hat eine eine
erwerbstätigkeit mann hat dinge gebend
kleine reaktor klein-klein boni der wert
gibt aber einen anderen sinn und hat
freizeiten und hat ferien engagiert sich
vielleicht politisch oder ihren verein
also für mich ist das sowie ein
portfolio oder von verschiedenen
tätigkeiten die einen ganz persönlichen
geben oder
und das muss jeder für sich selber
ausmachen was brauche ich um zu leben
auch eine gewisse eigenverantwortung
natürlich die auch ein wichtiger pfeiler
ist der schweiz die zweite zeile der
schweiz ist die solidarität da sind für
mich diese beiden grundprinzipien die ja
auch diesen generationenvertrag
ausmachen
und jetzt ging jedoch zurück zu diesen
generationenvertrag weil ich da schon
auch wirklich noch dran bleiben möchte
es gibt zum beispiel einen jugendrat der
generationen stiftung in deutschland die
sagen ganz klar sie wollen den
generationen vertrag kündigen die
pflastern in deutschland die städte zu
mit dem versuch neben den generationen
vertrag zu kündigen und das anliegen ist
natürlich nicht einfach jetzt nur nur im
sinne von nicht alleine diese angst wir
werden in zukunft die renten finanzieren
welche last kommt auf uns zu sondern
sehr stark diese klimafrage wo sie auch
sagen die generation die jetzt
pensioniert ist hinterlässt den jungen
einen havarierten planeten sind wir
einmal ehrlich
und in diesem kontext kommt ja auch die
frage auf das der senkung des
stimmrechtsalters also die frage wer
macht eigentlich die regeln die vor
allem dann die jungen betreffen werden
und ich würde in diesem kontext ganz
gerne kurzen paar jungen politikern und
politikern ein das wort geben
ich bin sehr stark fürs stimme nachts
holten sascha es ist demokratiepolitisch
wirklich notwendig auch die bevölkerung
ich bin heute tag sich die mädchen
wählen die 750 jahr altersbedingt unter
750 gleichviel stimmgewicht hand wird
lied über 750 und gerade in anbetracht
dessen dass jetzt so wichtige
weichenstellung auf wie klimawandel
brand telefon der münchner keine
bestimmende zins jahr engagiert wie
klima streikzeit und die tante aus in
trance und das sollte sie auch für
kunden und die wichtige politische thema
sind aber das stört ist das sind das
werk wiesen die entscheid zukunft was
die jugend wichtig ist es mit dem sieg
setzten reihe erhält vom rentenalter
oder baby klimathemen also ich glaube
der österreicher toto und da darf man
schon sagen ich glaube eben puncto klima
ist es nicht so einfach wie diese diese
gruppierung in deutschland das
vielleicht sich macht ich glaube eben
einerseits gab es ja schon immer
klimabewegung club of rome das sind die
die heute pensioniert sind anders sie
ist bei der heutigen überhaupt nicht das
umfassende ökologische bewusstsein da
oder viel mehr als bei anderen
bevölkerungsschichten
also ich glaube es sind politische
kämpfe die sich entlang und auch
zwischen den generationen abspielen
umgekehrt also meine stimmrechtsalter 16
ist für mich eine selbstverständlichkeit
wenn man dann wirklich auch eben dieses
gleichgewicht wieder ein bisschen mehr
herstellen will
gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen dass es
ja auch so ist dass die alten halt eben
abstimmen gehen sich damit befassen und
die jungen zu einem großen teil nicht
also hat sie haben das auch wieder
selber in der hand
politisch sich einzubringen und zu
engagieren
der philosoph benjamin kiesewetter hat
uns ein interview gegeben das kann man
auf unserer website nachlesen und
erfordert ein stimmrechtsalter 0 also im
grunde
genommen jedes kind hat bereits ein
stimmrecht ein wahlrecht die eltern
haben das treuhänderisch wahr zu nehmen
anstelle des kindes bis das kind nicht
bis 18 sondern bis das kind selber bei
einer stelle kunst tut dass es mit reden
was haben sie davon
das würde natürlich einiges ändern in
den verhältnissen
ich bin nicht sicher also ich komme in
der demokratietheorie komme ich sehr
stark von diesem unterworfen heinz
prinzip her also dass alle die gesetzen
unterworfen sind quasi der staat auch
sie zugreift macht auf sie ausübt ohne
dass man dem vielleicht zugestimmt hat
dass man dann einen anspruch hat darüber
mit zu bestimmen
naja sind nach dem unterwarf genau was
fünfjähriges kind und verworfen den
autobahnen vor meinem haus gebaut wird
genau nein ich glaube eben darum brutal
über kann man durchaus diskutieren die
kann man die stimmen der kinder quasi
einbeziehen darin aber der andere punkt
ist dass das diese haltung gehe fest
davon aus auch wieder
wir sind kinder wir haben diese
interessen wir sind alte wir haben diese
interessen und die werden wir dann in
der politik zusammen und da bin ich
schon als philosophie der überzeugung
dass wir uns eben wenn wir uns mit
argumenten auseinandersetzen wenn wir
mit dem schleier des nichtwissens
versuchen in andere perspektiven herein
zu begeben und die bestmöglichen
politischen lösungen zu finden dass wir
dann eben nicht zwingend nur unsere
position und unsere interessen vertreten
sondern schauen wie können wir das
problem
gesamtgesellschaftlich lösen also
insofern wars mit dem schleier des
nichtwissens dieses gedankenexperiment
dass wir bei geburt es uns vorstellen
die wüssten nicht welches geschlecht wir
haben wo wir geboren werden in welche
familie hinein und so weiter das
genommen würde ich nicht in alten
vorwerfen dass sie per serie nicht hier
in das rentensystem regulierten morgen
oder dass sie passierte jungen aus
nehmen möchten
das ist ein bisschen sogar hintergrund
stimmrechtsalter 0 was denken sie gut
das ist wenn man bekommt irgendein thema
denken ist einfach sehr
institutionalisiert wieder dass er
wie kann ich meine stimme ausdruck
verleihen oder und das ist die
institutionalisierte form ja aber es
gibt ja auch ganz ganz viele nicht
institutionalisierte form und da komme
ich wieder auf die klimadebatte zu
sprechen ich meine da war diese junge
junge frauen die die da eine bewegung
losgelöst haben dth auch nicht immer
stimmen alters oder man kann auch
bewegen auf andere art und weise und die
klimabewegung hat das ganz klar gezeigt
also ich glaube man kann über das
diskutiert aber für mich ist das gar
nicht nicht das entscheidend ist anders
entscheiden wird aber nicht wirklich bei
ihnen ist wirklich wie diskutieren die
generationen miteinander und ich glaube
die schweiz hat das wirklich immer
geschafft auch auf demokratisches land
da wirklich lösungen zu finden und ich
hoffe wirklich sehe dass das bei diesen
bei der revision
diese ist im ganzen sozialen säulen dass
das dass das auch gelingt
und wenn ich sage ich stelle mir auf
andere formen vor wie das rein
institutionalisierte stimm und wahlrecht
oder einander sehen wir haben von
verwaltungsseite angesprochen hat man
das gefühl es braucht es dort
digitalisierungs leute oder es braucht
junge leute dann sage ich immer ja aber
als verwaltungsrat muss waren über alle
themen mitsprechen können
das heißt es braucht auch eine gewisse
erfahrung und dann sage ich warum macht
man nicht einen beirat beispielsweise
einen beirat an bord war nichts mit
jungen leuten zusammen stellt die
kundinnen und kunden dieses unternehmen
sind und dass man dann regelmäßig so und
jetzt als verwaltungsrat das meine ich
ein bisschen auch dass man sich ein
bisschen löst von diesen gegebenen
strukturen und institutionen und eben
auch den nutzen die haben heute nicht
wir haben nicht über die digitalisierung
gesprochen aber auch da ich mein was da
abgeht auch mit der ganzen mit diesen
plattformen an diese möglichkeiten leute
zusammenbringen auf digitaler ebene
und da denke ich ist eben auch wieder
ein potenzial für die ältere generation
einzubeziehen
und es gibt da tolle start up sie das
machen und darf mehr zu nutzen wie schon
wieder zu sagen
ähnliche institutionen was vermutlich
sowieso eine illusion aber noch noch
einmal vielleicht würden sie denn dass
zum beispiel wollen herr hasler also
konkret gefragt dieses billig war 65
jahre eingebunden noch einmal in einer
arbeit da musste ich aufstehen ich
musste da erscheinen
ich hatte meine zehen vielen pflichten
daneben habe ich vielleicht kinder
großgezogen dann kommt eine phase da
möchte ich freier sein möchten sie denn
wieder in dieser art und weise
eingebunden sein würden sich da melden
bei frau emmy für diese projekte die man
sich aber natürlich genug zu tun ist und
wie viel gefragter redner überall
unterwegs aber wenn sie an ihre publikum
denken ja aber das ist das ist eine
frage des menschenbildes
was ist der mensch eigentlich also ich
kann einfach jetzt ich kenne das auch
theoretisch natürlich jetzt erläutern
aber ich kann auch sagen was sind meine
erfahrung also die beste gelaunten orten
die ich kenne die massen war das ist
einerseits also wir haben das ist die
perspektive von 57 jährigen im raum
stadtrat die jeden morgen aufstehen
müssen und eigentlich ihre arbeit nicht
zwingend lieben oder so
die denken wenn das mal ein ende hat
dann bin ich glücklich ja und dann also
es gibt auch statistiken die zeigen und
depressionen nimmt zu alkoholismus nimmt
krass zu übrigens ich könnte von ich
könnte geschichten erzählen von von
gleichaltrigen die feudal leben aber sie
sind depressiv weil sie einfach sich
nicht mehr gebraucht fühlen sie sind sie
finden sind ausgemustert weg gestellt
sind keine akteure mehr so komme ich auf
die passive mitgliedschaft gar nicht
immer frei gewählt ist dass das ist also
müssen wir dann nicht auch darüber
sprechen hat der generationenvertrag
dann nicht auch versagt mit blick darauf
wie dieses gespräch funktioniert das
dann könnte man dann ja den jüngeren den
vorwurf machen dass sie viel zu wenig
auf die ältere generation zu gehen oder
umgekehrt also ich sehe ist eigentlich
eher umgekehrt ich empfinde meine
generation mich nicht ganz
ausgeschlossen
im prinzip also tendenziell ein bisschen
besser liegt
also wir sind wir sind auch sehr
selbstzufrieden also wir sind gern mit
dem rotstift unterwegs recht also wir
wir haben uns sozusagen von der bühne
dass das maßgeblichen verabschiedet
sitzen im paket schauen wie machen es
jetzt die jungen und eigentlich finden
wir ja schon dass die jungen das jetzt
schon frech übernehmen nicht ist
natürlich auch unsere welt wir haben die
ja gemacht und so werden wir haben die
veranstalter das erlebe ich sehr häufig
auch reaktionen auf publikationen von
mir dann werden die texte fotografiert
mehr zugesandt und irgendein ein wort
oder ein begriff wird ein geklingelt
fehler jeder spruch kassner
da ist ein durchbruch da ist ein fehler
und so weiter also dieses kritisieren
dieses besseres und ich finde es liegt
sehr starken uns wenn wir als wertvolle
mitglieder dieser gesellschaft geachtet
werden wollen recht was wir ja immer
sagen und so keine diskriminierung und
so weiter wir wollen wirklich geschätzt
werden dann müssen wir uns auch
entsprechend benehmen dann müssen wir
die jungen unterstützen und zwar nicht
besserwisserisch sondern wir müssen
ihnen helfen wir müssen ihnen zuhören
keinmal weil das mit stimmrecht 0
das ist als idee ist ja das tor
denn es heißt wir sollten in unser
politisches hand und die perspektive
frisch geborener lieben mit einbeziehen
darum geht es in der praxis glaube ich
sehe ich das eigentlich nicht aber als
idee und darum das ist doch so schön
wenn wir aus alte den jungen zu hören
weil die jungen haben zukunft ich hab
meine schrumpft allmählich nicht meine
zukunft und dann kann ich teilhaben an
einer zukunft und da wir haben eine
meiner lieblingsstädte ich kann
teilhaben an einer zukunft auch wenn
diese zukunft nicht mehr meine sein wert
das ist für uns in diesen gedanken sind
sie verliebt haben sie
in einem interview gesagt möchte noch
ein anderes bild einbringen nämlich dass
hier das bild einer kathedrale und das
kommt in ihrem buch vor und das hat mich
das hat mich so begeistert weil sie das
auch so schön schreiben sie erzählen
eine parabel von drei steinmetze die
treffen sich der erste sagt ich habe
steine der zweite sagt ich habe steine
und verdiene damit mein geld und der
dritte sagt ich baue mit an der
kathedrale und sie sagen darum geht es
im lebensglück mitbauen an der
kathedrale und jetzt wäre meine frage
was ich denn diese kathedrale hermann
sah also für mich ist es ganz klar eine
gesellschaft in der sich alle möglichst
frei entfalten können und eben auch eine
autonome selbstbestimmtes leben führen
in all diesen hinsichten und das beginnt
das heißt automatisch auch dass man sich
einbringen will dass man solidarisch ist
über die generationen und über das auto
hinweg ich glaube wirklich das problem
ist zwischen diesen zwischen dem zweiten
und dem dritten steinmetz der zweite
sagte ich mache das um geld zu verdienen
und dass wir da selbst fest noch darin
gefangen sind oder dass wir sagen die
jungen sollen arbeiten sie sollen unsere
renten finanzieren die alten haben wir
haben gearbeitet wir lassen uns jetzt
finanzieren
und dass das alles fest an diese
monetäre vorstellung von leistung und
beitrag gebunden ist was für das
rentensystem sehr problematisch ist aber
eben auch für frauen im alter weil weil
die ganze kernarbeit unbezahlt ist also
nicht aus beitrag geht und ich glaube
deshalb müssen wir das so zusammen
denken dass wir schauen wir können weil
ich glaube die meisten menschen sind die
dritten steinmetze sie wollen an dieser
gesellschaft mit bauen
aber sie müssen vielleicht arbeiten um
überhaupt zu überleben
und ich glaube da ist wirklich die frage
die sie auch aufgeworfen haben was wir
alles scheint mir machen
wie können wir das tun was wir wollen
und nicht was wir müssen und damit auch
noch geld verdienen oder oder die
wertschätzung erhalten unabhängig von
ihr trennen und das ist eine eminent
philosophische frage wie bauen wir
gesellschaft als kathedrale an der alle
mitwirken können das hat vor allem zb
wollte oder whiskey hat das sehr
beschäftigt diese idee oder auch jean
jacques rousseau
was sagen sie als operation libero wenn
sie die politik gestalten können
gesellschaft
gestalten können wir kriegen wir denn
dieses bild einer kathedrale hin
ich glaube ich bezeichne häufig als
verfassungs patrioten und ich glaube die
liberale verfassung ist ein bild oder
ein staatsgebilde was sehr schön ein
sehr schönes versprechen in dieser
hinsicht wir haben diese grundrechte
diese gleichheit diese freiheit von
allen
und jetzt müssen und wir haben ok wir
schaffen wir das umzusetzen
und ich glaube einerseits geht es darum
dass wir alle am politischen prozess
teilhaben können wo wir in der schweiz
längstens nicht sind wir um 25 prozent
ausländerinnen und ausländer die keinen
kein stimmrecht haben oder formell und
andererseits eben auch über diese fragen
wer kann über hat sie überhaupt die zeit
beizutragen wer muss arbeiten um
überhaupt über die runden zu kommen
vielleicht im alter kommt immer noch
nicht über die grundmiete hv also
wirklich diese fragen die ich finde hat
dass die debatte um das grundeinkommen
sehr schön aufgeworfen wie können wir
alle an der gesellschaft teilhaben wie
finanzieren wir das ohne dass wir davon
ausgehen eben die einen haben sich schon
erarbeitet die verdienen als die anderen
müssen noch arbeiten mit dem mit dem
grundmisstrauen dass leute das nicht tun
wollen was sie am liebsten sich nur
finanzieren lassen wird seien es die
ausländer seines menschen über 65 oder
seien es heute wenn wir ein
grundeinkommen
was ist die kathedrale fifa
das ist die welt und dann die sind ein
bisschen egoistischer die schweiz ja
aber es ist schon der beitrag den wir
alle leisten müssen dass die welt
so funktionieren kann wie sie wie sie
funktionieren so dass bisher halten
können für die nächsten generationen das
ist mir wichtig das sind aktuelle themen
sind natürlich jetzt im moment sind die
ganzen klimathemen aber das verbindet
uns alle das haben wir vorher gesehen da
glaube ich gibt es kleine 15 jungen dort
wo ich eine große veränderung sehe in
der nächsten zeit ist der begriff der
arbeit was ist arbeit was ist bezahlte
arbeit das ist nicht bezahlte arbeit auf
die ganze arbeitswelt jetzt ohne in die
details zu gehen ändert sich im moment
sehr stark hin zu mehr agilität mehr
effizienz mehr individualität dezentrale
arbeiten und ich glaube das sind alles
entwicklungen die mit helfen eben damit
sich alle generationen mitglieder ob
jetzt ältere oder jüngere erwerbstätige
die nicht erwerbstätig in irgendeiner
form einbringen können und das wäre mein
ansatz wie ich alleine auch eine
revision der dass der sozialwerke ging
oder mit diesem gedanken und sich eben
lösen von den klassischen traditionellen
linearen karrieren es ist wunderbar
beschrieben haben
die logischerweise die ältere generation
einfach die sorge ist dass ich das ist
ganz tief drinnen das ist doch nichts
das ist auch kein vorwurf überhaupt
nicht sondern das ist so und darum
müssen wir uns auflösen von diesen
stereotypen oder die alten sind so die
jungen sind so die fragen sind so die
männer sind so das bringt uns nicht
weiter im gegenteil an dem finde ich
sollten wir arbeiten das loslösen von
diesen stereotypen und wenn wir diese
arbeit leisten neue überarbeit
nachdenken dann wird es ja eben auch
mehr möglichkeiten geben damit alle
ihren beitrag zur kathedrale leisten
können ich möchte gerne zum schluss herr
hasler noch einmal mit etwas provokative
sie konfrontieren aber etwas was ich
auch sehr schön fand sie sagen nämlich
aufs hohe alter hin
da ist es vielleicht nicht mehr so dass
dieser beitrag zu dieser kathedrale der
stein den ich da im den ich bereue den
kann ich vielleicht hier passgenau in
die kathedrale einfügen es gibt nämlich
zum alter hin
eine lizenz zum verdoppeln sie meinen
das aber positiv sie sagen es gibt
vielleicht auch so was ihnen recht
darauf sich zu entspannen
was ist die lizenz zum vertrauten
einsetzt ja ich stehe tatsächlich als
alle autos gelehrten reden ja vom
dritten auf den vierten alt und wir
reden jetzt eigentlich hier immer vom
dritten lauter dass das heißt dass ich
eigentlich noch gar kein anderer sondern
es gibt uns einfach schon lange und wir
wir leben schon weiter eigentlich sind
wir noch recht jung und munter und da
ist die kathedrale das entscheidende
das ist wenn ich das nur kurz ergänzen
darf ich denke natürlich viel und auch
viel konkret sie denken und an die
schweiz politik und so weiter und sie
denkt an die welt ich denke zum beispiel
an eine dort bayerischen die nur
überlebt wenn 3 75 jährige sich dort
engagieren
ich denke ich so ganz in kleinen ich
denke an all die seniorenräte die es
zustande bringen dass die wir alten
sozusagen wieder die akteure unserer
eigenen welt sind wir machen alles wir
müssen doch nicht alles delegieren an
irgendwelchen institutionen
wir können ja alle können etwas alle
müssen etwas alle handhaben etwas machen
wird auch da sind dann sind wir die
akteure aber irgendwann lassen die
kräfte nach und dann beginnt das alter
wie es immer war
dann sind der hilfsbedürftigen die
beschwerden kommen und die schmerzen und
so weiter ja und dann sage ich gibt es
eine lizenz zu vertrocknen also eher
nicht mehr so tun müssen als wären wir
noch leistungs subjekte als wären wir
noch die akteure eben wie automat war
das natürlich immer wunderbar gefeiert
hat auch an sich selbst er hat das auch
so gelebt manchmal gibt nach man man ist
sozusagen man fühlt sich aus der der
heitere komödiant des welttheaters
gewissermaßen
man meldet sich nicht unbedingt von der
bühne aber man ist nur noch der
zuschauer nicht und hängt sich an
allerlei dinge die über einen hinaus
gehen also ich bei mir hat das schon
begonnen nicht das große vertrocknen
aber das abziehen von mir also indem ich
eine stunde lang den flug der lars eklat
beobachte uns sozusagen selber aus mehr
rauskomme und dadurch stehen den blauen
himmels liege und dass diese zeit kann
man sich wenn man ihr buch liest
irgendwie auch schon fast wieder freuen
ich danke ganz ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch vl die herr hasler hermann sie
vielen dank dass sie daran ja auch ess
kultur widmet sich dieses wochenende
intensiv dem gespräch zwischen den
generationen und speziell den jahrgang
2000 der dieses jahr den zwanzigsten
geburtstag feiert schauen sie rein
die porträts und geschichten ist lohnt
sich nächste woche begibt sich mein
kollege wolfram eilenberger mit dem
philosophen michael hampe in die wildnis
auf der suche nach dem wahren leben
ich hoffe mal er geht da nicht verloren
und jetzt gleich gehen wir der magie des
bolero von maurice ravel auf die spur
kaum ein werk wurde so häufig adaptiert
variiert und neu entdeckt lassen auch
sie sich rein ziehen in den sog dieser
musik danke fürs interesse eine gute
zeit und bis bald
[Musik]